فاذا مشاهدينا الى صناديق الاقتراع توجه
مواطنوا استونيا لاختيار اعضاء البرلمان
الجديد في انتخابات تخيم ما عليها ظلال
الازمه الاوكرانيه يعد الامن القومي في
عقبه هجوم روسيا المجاوره على اوكرانيا
والقضايا الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه من
القضايا الرئيسيه للانتخابات عندما نحينا
السياسه الداخليه جانبا فتشكل حرب
اوكرانيا عاملا مهما في هذه الانتخابات
استونيا كانت اشد الداعمين لاوكرانيا منذ
بدايه الحرب الدوله الواقعه في منطقه
البلطيق والعضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي
والناتو على راس الدول التي اطلقت نداءات
دوليه العامه الماضي لزياده المساعدات
العسكريه لاوكرانيا في مواجهه الغزو
الروسي لم تكتفي استونيا بالدعوه لدعم
اوكرانيا بل انها تعتبر اكبر دوله مساهمه
في الجهود الغربيه بالمقارنه مع اقتصادها
بانفاقها اكثر من 1% من نتجها المحلي على
دعم اوكرانيا سياسيا وعسكريا استونيا بحسب
احصاءات رسميه سلمت الى اوكرانيا ترسانتها
الكامله من مدافع من بين معدات اخرى كما
انها استقبلت اكثر من 62 الف لاجئ
الاوكراني في اعلى نسبه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي قياسا بعدد السكان اما على صعيد
العقوبات تريد استونيا اقرارا تخفيض فوريا
لسقف اسعار النفط الروسي وفرد قيود مماثله
على صادرات الغاز الطبيعي من موسكو الدعم
الاستوني لاوكرانيا تحدث عنه وزير
الخارجيه اورما سالو لمجله نيوزويك قائلا
ان الدول الغربيه مازالت تقدم لاوكرانيا
ما تحتاجه للبقاء وليس للنصر مطالبا
بزياده الدعم الغربي واضاف الوزير ان ايام
انتصار لروسيا سيضع الغرب في ورطه وربما
قد يؤدي هذا لمسح استونيا من الخريطه على
حد قوله على الجانب الاخر يرزائم حزب
الشعب المحافظ مارتن هيل ان على استونيا
تجنب زياده حده التوتر مع موسكو كما يركز
الحزب على حملته على معارضه تقديم مساعده
عسكريه اضافيه لاوكرانيا وعدم استقبال
مزيد من اللاجئين الاوكرانيين او من
جنسيات اخرى
[موسيقى]
تاريخ استونيا داخل بالكثير من المحطات
المؤلمه لشعبها سيطر عليها الاتحاد
السوفيتي عام 1940 ثم استولت على البلاد
قوته المانيا النازيه بعدها بعام قبل ان
تعود للسيطره السوفيتيه عام 1944 ولم
تغادر حتى نالت البلاد استقلالها عام 1991
خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه قتل ما يقدر
بنحو ربع المواطنين الاستونيين في واحد من
اعلى المعدلات في كل اوروبا ثم ادت عقود
من السيطره السوفيتيه الى عمليه ترحيل
جماعي واختفاء رئيسه الوزراء الحاليه كايا
كلاس اعادت ربط الحاضر باحداث الحرب
العالميه الثانيه خلال كلمه لها الشهر
الماضي امام مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
[موسيقى]
يمكن للجميع رؤيه ما يتحدث عنه بوتين انه
جاد بالفعل في عام
1925 لم يصدق احد هتلر لكنه كان واضحا في
اهدافه وفي عام 2007 كان بوتين هنا في هذا
المؤتمر واضح جدا بشان اهداف روسيا كانت
المشكله ان احدا لم يصدق ولكن دعونا نصدقه
الان لنتمكن من اتخاذ القرارات على
المديين المتوسطي والطويل
الشان الاوكراني كان حاضرا وبقوه على
مناقشات الحملات الانتخابيه في عده دول
اوروبيه خلال الاشهر الماضيه في ايطاليا
مثلا حدث تباين بين اطراف الائتلاف
الثلاثي الذي فاز في انتخابات سبتمبر
الماضي فبينما اعلنت جورجيا ميلوني دعمها
لاوكرانيا كان حليفاها في الائتلاف ماتيو
سالفينيو وسلفيو على علاقات وثيقه مع
موسكو حتى ان بيلسكون اعتبر ان الرئيس
الروسي
دفع بل دفع دفعا لغزو اوكرانيا في اكتوبر
الماضي لم يؤثر الخلاف السياسي الداخلي في
السويد على توجهات ستوكه من الدعم
اوكرانيا في وقت تواصل فيه السويد سعيها
للانضمام للناتو وبين يساري ويمين المشهد
السياسي السويدي تواصل السويد مع اوكرانيا
حتى بعد وصول حزب ديمقراطيه السويد اليمني
للسلطه
[موسيقى]